on va parler des réseaux sociaux et on
sait que les réseaux sociaux sont dans
le nouveau terrain de chasse des marques
elle adore les réseaux sociaux mais mais
pas seulement puisqu'il serait aussi
celui des lobbys et notamment des lobbys
pharmaceutiques
c'est ce que nous explique le magazine
de la santé sur france 5
tu viens de famille influence euse qui a
posté cette photo avec ces granules
d'homéopathie est elle à cette légende à
côté qui dit les petites granules
dernier cas nous accompagne comme
beaucoup de parents depuis presque six
ans nous avons d'ailleurs un tube dans
chaque pièce de la maison cette mère de
famille a été interpellé pour savoir si
elles avaient été rémunérées pour avoir
posté cette photo et cette légende et
elle répond ben oui bien sûr une
collaboration rémunérée le laboratoire
boiron a aussi révélé au lieu au journal
libération qu'ils allaient bien
rémunérés cette influence us et bien
d'autres sur instagram pour cette
campagne de publicité a justement est ce
que la publicité pour certains produits
de santé va prendre vraiment de
l'ampleur sur les réseaux alors pour
l'instant les laboratoires sont reste
relativement frileux ils font plutôt des
campagnes pour leur image
il est vrai que demain on va avoir de la
publicité sur les médicaments sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est certain alors je
me tourne vers les médecins de la bande
vous trouvez que c'est une chose saine
d'avoir des de la publicité pour des
médicaments sur les réseaux sociaux
alors que c'est interdit on ne peut pas
en faire tout justement c'est une façon
de contourner la loi parce qu'on n'a pas
le droit de faire de la publicité pour
les médicaments alors c'est un peu plus
relax pour des produits comme
l'homéopathie qui sont pas vraiment
étiquetés comme médicament en tout cas
précis ce qui se vend sans ordonnance
est une façon de contourner la
législation et c'est pas bien et puis
ensuite faut pas être du coi instagram
c'est un réseau qui est là pour faire de
l'argent il ya les influenceurs qui
touchent de l'argent il ya des marques
qui s'en servent pour faire une
publicité à pas cher d'ailleurs parce
que par exemple des filles comme car on
les paye que dalle quoi mais là ça prix
là effectivement la sarthe est ce que là
on touche pas les limites du genre parce
qu'effectivement c'est un produit comme
un autre la cde sont des produits de
santé carolyn vous me dites non à mais
moi ça ne me choque pas du tout je
trouve pas du tout ça malsain ou qu'ils
ont raison pour le consommateur vous
savez qu'il a un cerveau et que dans un
cerveau il ya des trucs qui fonctionne
donc il est capable aussi lui même de
faire la différence en dix ans j'adhère
ou j'adhère pas ça parce que la fille
devaient être payés ou pas payé en tant
que 15 fluence ze ce que ça va influer
mais sur mon opinion mais pas du tout
mais tu vois là en l'occurrence me dis
bah en plus le mot pas tiqué quand même
hein
univers qui vraiment ils sont et doivent
se débrouiller tout seuls ils n'ont pas
de soutien on les prend pour des
charlatans et on sait très bien qu'ils
profitent effectivement d'instagram où
il ya un flou juridique dans lequel on
peut un petit peu s'immiscer pour parler
de ce produit c'est pas plus chaud qu'on
parlait de s'accaparer d'un mois que
j'accepte barrière lalalalala y avait
une chose plutôt formidable c'est
qu'elle n'avançait pas formidable en
tout cas positif c'est qu'elle
n'avançait pas masquer la dame quand on
lui demandait ce qu'effectivement c'est
une publicité que vous faites elle
résonne dit oui il a raison
je suis d'accord avec elle quand il dit
ça n'influence pas les gens d'ailleurs
le mot influenceurs est fait pour ça
quand elle il ne se contente pas
d'utiliser cette femme comme
influenceurs ils vont en prendre 50 donc
ton réseau va être inondé de ce type de
choses et à la fin ça imprègne ton
cerveau et tu finiras par acheter de
l'arnica dites nous ce que vous en
pensez à laisser aux influenceurs là qui
font du lobbying pour pour des
l'occurrence l'homéopathie on vous a
posé la question il vous nous dites que
c'est scandaleux pour 78% mais normal
pour 22% n'hésitez pas à continuer à
réagir avec le hashtag sécu des lt